gluten-free diets and products are
everywhere these days as of 2014 an
estimated 3 million people in the US
alone had sworn off gluten so what we
don't know from those numbers is how
many of those people were avoiding
gluten because they heard that the
gluten-free diet is healthy or they
heard that gluten is just bad for
everyone which it's not versus people
who are actually experiencing some kind
of symptom and attributing that to
gluten some people blame gluten for
symptoms like abdominal pain bloating
and fatigue but don't have celiac
disease the autoimmune reaction to this
villainized complex of proteins found in
wheat barley and rye those are the cases
that some doctors and researchers are
really puzzling over ends from trying to
get to the bottom of
[Music]
here's what we know certain researchers
are convinced that some people have an
immune reaction to gluten or to some
other substance in wheat a study
published in 2016
tested blood samples from 80 patients
who had symptoms after eating wheat it
found that these patients had higher
levels of a class of antibodies against
a component of gluten the team also
found elevated levels of two proteins
that indicate an inflammatory response
to bacteria this doesn't necessarily
mean gluten itself was causing illness
but the researchers proposed that some
part of wheat prompts the intestinal
lining to become more permeable then the
wheat components and gut bacteria sneak
past immune cells in the intestinal
tissue make their way to the bloodstream
and liver and cause inflammation but
another camp thinks most patients don't
have an immune reaction to eat instead
they believe that most are really
reacting to an excess of FODMAPs
fermentable all ago die monosaccharides
and polyols so it's this category of
carbohydrates that are not easily
absorbed by the intestines and so they
can ferment in the gut and that can
cause gas and bloating FODMAPs are
widespread in our diets carbohydrates in
wheat called fruit tense could account
for as much as half of a person's fodmap
intake some researchers believe that
many people feel better after
eliminating wheat from their diet not
because of an immune reaction to gluten
or other wee components but because
they're reducing their FODMAPs
proponents of a low fodmap diet say it's
less restrictive than going totally
gluten-free because people can
reintroduce FODMAPs to find a threshold
that keeps their symptoms in check so
this group based at the University of
Oslo in Norway designed the study to
sort of try to tease out the effects of
FODMAPs
versus gluten and what they did was they
recruited people who were already on
free diet and they had them try one of
three different indistinguishable snack
bars that had either pure gluten or a
fodmap called fruit ten or neither a
placebo bar and they would eat one of
the bars for a week report their
abdominal symptoms and then switch until
they had tried all three of the bars
without knowing which was which in the
end FODMAPs caused the worst symptoms by
a small margin and also more than a
third of the people in the study
reported their worst symptoms after the
placebo bar it was a mess so the
researchers concluded that in most cases
FODMAPs were the culprit sort of
generally in the population people were
reacting to FODMAPs not something
specifically in wheat but there's been
skepticism about that study people who
say that well you didn't really recruit
the people who are likely to have an
immune reaction to wheat and not to
fodmap so the case is not closed rather
than one single cause or culprit the
illness is attributed to gluten may
actually be due to multiple nuanced
conditions so how will this affect our
choices at the grocery store and at the
dinner table well don't do anything to
dressed yet experts say if you suspect
you're reacting to wheat see a doctor
and rule out celiac disease before going
gluten-free a dietitian can also help
manage symptoms without cutting out so
many foods that you're missing out on
important nutrients because there aren't
a lot of good answers about the possible
causes of these conditions a lot of
people when they go to the doctor or to
a dietician are still being encouraged
to just experiment try cutting out
gluten and see if it works for them so
that's sort of where we are right now I
think a lot of people are just sort of
figuring out what makes them feel best
[Music]